let's go to the mess right now at
Southwest Airlines this morning
FlightAware reports more than 2500
Southwest flights have already been
canceled Nationwide and more are
expected yeah let's go and take a look
now Southwest representative told us
yesterday afternoon they had about 3 000
unclaimed bags just sitting outside of
the baggage Services office look at that
you can imagine how difficult that makes
actually finding your bag
do you even know if it's here right now
no I have no idea the line that I was
standing in is to just get into baggage
claim to speak to a person I had to go
out and buy
clothes toiletries I have prescriptions
you know just think about the things
that we travel with every day
yeah they're just so many tangents of
this local Southwest Air Representatives
say they are offering flight vouchers
and accommodation when possible
according to FlightAware already today
at Harry Reid more than 200 total
flights have been canceled and 190 of
those are Southwest flights so just a
reminder if you're flying or even trying
to pick someone up at the airport double
triple check before you head out the
door you know we had Candace Charles
live at read International with Santa
Claus last week right he's been there
this week as well and Candace no Santa
Claus this time it's just a lot of
frustrated people Yeah a different mood
if you are caught in the travel chaos
there are some things that you can do
though Candace go ahead and give it take
us away
good morning YouTube good morning folks
you guys are absolutely right I was here
last week with a whole different vibe a
lot of people here as you can imagine
are upset are frustrated I mean they're
tired they've been sleeping many of them
really on the ground here a lot of
people are looking for their bags
Southwest teams here are working hard to
connect some of these bags with people
and you know what I've heard from Pastor
rights Advocates that really that's what
they will try to do especially if you
ask for things nicely as soon as you
know that you have a delay or a
cancellation you want to go to the desk
right away have your phone in hand and
call the center as well whichever one
you get to first know what you want to
ask for whether that's a hotel voucher
or a food voucher know your airline's
customer service plan Southwest which we
which currently has the most delays and
cancellations as we've mentioned has a
customer service plan that says they
only will give flight and Mill vouchers
for cancellations that are with in their
control whether unfortunately is not
what we've seen earlier today a little
form that they are passing out to folks
saying that they will give you a voucher
for your gas a car that you may rent of
course you got to keep all of your
receipts for that and again Travel
Experts say advocate for yourself if
you'd like to be put on another Airlines
flight ask unfortunately Southwest does
not partner with other airlines but
Delta American a few others do be ready
to ask for any and all of these things
nicely Pastor rights Advocates tell me
that anything is possible
ask them nicely if there's a reason the
airline will indeed pay the full fare to
move you uh from one flight from your
originally scheduled flight to another
flight
in the airport terminal thank you now
people are excitedly getting in their
bags here I'm sure they've been waiting
for some time but remember each airline
has its own policies when it comes to
lays and cancellations there are no
federal requirements but you can file a
complaint with the U.S department of
transportation we have our link on our
website
8newsnow.com you guys can find out all
the details from more of the pastor
rights Advocates and whatever you need
from our website as I said a newsnow.com
for now live from here read
International I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now